let's talk about the week's developments
in Washington and elsewhere and for that
we turn to Priscilla Alvarez politics
editor and writer at the Atlantic
Priscilla good morning good morning
let's talk first about this this
devastating climate assessment we're
about to have a democratic house with a
new agenda how do you think this is
going to factor into that this is really
gonna fire up progressives and we've
already seen that in the wake of the
report so we have representative elect
Alexandria Ocasio Karthus has made this
a big part of her agenda she came in to
Congress earlier this month already
asking for an expansive plan to address
climate change in a tweet she's pressing
this forward a little more asking for a
select committee on climate change
so remember Democrats are going to helm
a lot of committees like House Energy
and Commerce Committee in the house
Science Committee and they are likely
going to make this a big priority moving
into the new Congress but the president
doesn't sound like he's gonna budge on
this no he wants he wants to move in
toward deregulating and he's done that
already with Obama era rule scaling them
back which had been to address other
issues with climate change like
greenhouse emissions but so far
progressives are really going to push
forward and this is something they came
into Congress wanting to tackle there
are other issues also for the president
though the idea the border wall and when
you look at the house how difficult it
is gonna be for the president to get his
agenda through now going forward so the
president has repeatedly asked for money
for his funding wall and he hasn't for
his border wall I should say and he
hasn't had much luck and he's in a very
tricky situation now because Democrats
are gonna take the house and they're
gonna be less willing to negotiate on
the border wall now there are some
issues that have come up we have the
legislation for protecting Bob more we
also have on the question citizenship
question and they want to strip from the
2020 census so these are things that
they that are likely to come up in
negotiations but they're in a tough in a
tough spot because Democrats are really
just gonna want to move forward with
this Senate Democrats have said they're
willing to give 1.6 billion but that's
still shy of the 5 billion dollars so
the confrontation will come to a head
before that December 7th date
I mean well as the Democrats get set to
take control of the House Nancy Pelosi
is is facing some leadership challenges
she doesn't seem to have a clear
opponent at this point but how secure is
she
well this Wednesday we're gonna have the
closed-door caucus vote and so she just
needs a simple majority to be nominated
as the nominee for the speaker for the
speaker position and there's not much
difficulty that we see arising there but
rather in January she's gonna need the
majority 218 votes to really take the
gavel and the clear advantage here is
that there really is no alternative
those had who had considered a potential
bid for speaker like representative
Marsha fudge
now supports Pelosi and so that's what
and again it's a long time until January
so that's a lifetime in politics and
she's gonna be brokering deals with
Democrats who oppose her and what's the
overall agenda for Democrats what does
that look like primarily investigations
that's going to be a big part of this
remember they're going to have the
helming the House Intelligence Committee
the House Oversight Committee at House
Foreign Affairs Committee they have
subpoena power now they can pressure the
administration to turn over documents
and so that's gonna be a big part of the
agenda and other issues like climate
change will surely come up with both
progressives and possibly immigration
reform down the line quickly will it
have an impact yes or no it's gonna
pressure the administration it's not
going to be a fun time for a president
Trump news every day Alvarez thank you
thank you and tomorrow morning on Face
the Nation here on CBS Margaret
Brennan's guests will include
independent senators Bernie Sanders of
Vermont and angus King of Maine